we've got another interesting story here
uh this one is a little bit lighter I
know we've been talking about a lot of
dark topics tonight this is a dark topic
but it's so ridiculous that it seems
like something that might have come out
of an onion article which is part of why
I wanted to share it with all of you
since this is Jim cast and you know
maybe we should lean into the comedy a
little bit more but this is a very dark
episode we're talking about important
issues and this is also to be clear an
important issue but a pentagon typo has
leaked to millions of sensitive uh
messages being leaked to African nations
so basically there is a typo that
results has resulted in literal millions
of messages from the defense department
from the Pentagon
being leaked to Molly basically you have
to end your emails.mil so in the same
way that if you email someone at
gmail.com yep it's really yeah yep so
when you email someone at gmail.com
writeits.com commercial when it comes to
the military it's dot Miguel military if
it's to someone in Mali it's dot ml so a
lot of people at the Pentagon were not
typing the I and so they were sending
secret information and sensitive
information at the very least to this
African nation now now to be clear for
everyone in panics this is still a
serious problem uh but Johanna severe
who manages Molly's domain collected 117
000 emails since January of this year
and many more in years prior and there
they contain a lot of information about
the United States government and this is
a risk which is very real this could
very easily be exploited and what he
basically said is that his 10-year
contract managing that server expires
this week and it's clear that the emails
being sent there aren't slowing down
let's also mention that Molly is an ally
of Russia so not to stoke the uh Russia
Russia Russia Flames at the same time
this is pretty bad this is pretty bad
what do you guys think I think they
should have had it as dot military us
what's up so you cannot mistake you
cannot accidentally type wrong dot
something you have to well maybe a very
explicit word they probably military UK
and the Brits get it who worked at the
uh that worked at the Pentagon were so
horrifyingly inept and stupid maybe the
real problem with the Deep State isn't
that they have too much power maybe it's
that they are stupid and should not have
any jobs at all yeah they have so much
power for the I mean normal amount of
intelligence of a human being
interesting because the the spokesman
who came out to address this was like
look we are actually aware this has been
happening and the thing is we have no
way to fix it because basically they
can't change the dot mil so they just
need to like send out a pentagon-wide
email being like please please please be
very careful because there's no uh he
was saying there's no there's no
technical roadblock here I don't know if
that's actually true I'm not an
information technologist by any means
but uh it is interesting that ultimately
our national security comes down to
bureaucratic error well don't so many
things come down to bureaucratic error
if you look at you know the Biden
Administration and they're sending out
these executive orders to do all kinds
of things get the agencies to do all of
this kind of stuff and it is just
bureaucracy it's bureaucrats trying to
figure out the best way to implement
these things like look at HHS right
they're like oh okay we're gonna
Implement trans policy by forcing
insurance companies to cover all of
these different kind of surgeries the
agriculture department is like we're
going to stop paying for free lunches
for school kids if schools don't allow
boys to use girls bathrooms that's what
we're going to do so it's a it's a
massive amount of ineptitude I just
failure from these people agreed went to
nice State schools and now have jobs
that they don't want to lose and it
turns out that they're idiots and fools
that's the real problem that's the issue
that I see with can so many conspiracy
theories as well it would require like a
lot of these conspiracy theories would
require intelligent people to be
implementing these things and we are run
by fools so yes do we charge them with
treason because ignorance of the law is
not justification for breaking news sure
charge them with children fire them all
don't be ridiculous for everyone it's
the federal government I just get them
out of office save us a bunch of money
that's a position start over at the very
least I'll say I'm sympathetic to that
position one thing I'll mention you
brought up it's incompetent these
schools that uh are having funds
withheld from them for people to for
students to get lunches that was the
Department of Agriculture yeah good old
Tom vilsack who also decided that there
that that grants for Farmers from the
federal government should be based on
race first well then I really wanted
because we've got farmers and everyone
was like no nobody really cares about
this and I'm like we're covering the
story damn it we are covering the story
well there's this weird thing where like
every couple decades left Wingers become
more comfortable outwardly saying that
we need to give farming subsidies and
Farms to people uh not based on whether
they know how to farm whether they're
politics
you guys have tried the whole let's base
who gets to be a farmer and whose
Advantage is a farmer on if we like you
politically and not like whether you can
farm and treating all people who can
Farm well equally instead of having like
racial or political preferences now
um I I also want to mention Too part of
the irony here which is the school
lunches thing is probably the left's
number one issue to grandstand on and
this is why it's always stupid it's
always short-sighted when conservatives
say you know what we need to do we need
to go after the schools that and it
doesn't happen all that often but
whenever it does it gets a tremendous
amount of press from the left smearing
the right because of course it's awful
and it's terrible Optics but they'll say
look these heartless conservatives don't
want kids to get school lunches but then
when Bureau bureaucratic incompetence
results in kids not getting school
lunches we can't lay that at the feet of
the people who are comfortable with
completely incompetent bureaucracies
right it makes me think of like uh
someone's uh who takes hostages being
like can you believe that the police
department wants these hostages to
suffer because they won't give me a
that's like we always see in the movies
like you know uh if this person dies
it'll be your fault no it's yourself
I also have to say can you just put
yourself in this Dutch entrepreneur's
position who is like hello US Government
I appear to have too many of your emails
I don't think you need to be doing this
apparently this has been going on for
years and nobody stops doing it right
and finally like these levels what fools
and videos finally he goes to the media
and it's like this doesn't seem to be
resolving itself but I have these emails
and I don't want them and I don't think
you want to be sending them and I have
to leave
manages uh the domain for the government
of Mali and so he is saying like this is
happening and I just I just want to know
like did you call the Pentagon and be
like hello please help me like I I have
this weird first one Pentagon would be
like yeah there would be no way to get
there yeah so well I you know I want to
ask you this because you have more
experience working in Tech I know you're
working for minds.com for a while and
you have a technology background how
difficult would it have been for the
Pentagon over the course of the last 10
years it just kind of implement some
kind of software into the computers that
are being used there to set off a flag
if someone tries to email a dot ml email
address instead for sure yeah yeah I
mean why wasn't how difficult would
something like that have been from a
technological perspective I don't think
that would be I don't know for sure but
I would think that you could internally
block the dot ml uh uh what is that
called X extra code I don't know we
would call that but you could block that
uh maybe they didn't even know the
problem was happening though so they
didn't block it it's I mean it of course
it sounds like he had been saying things
but yeah maybe I mean maybe this is one
of those things that people just never
flagged or considered to be important
enough to run up to the top but it seems
like a pretty massive vulnerability that
there's a country I'm wondering
if you guys want to get off at five and
go home yeah this one Dutch guy is like
what are we doing they're like what's
what's molly gonna do let's go home
we're fine we're gonna we're going home
for the evening I'm not gonna fix this I
I think it's also like there's probably
like I want to say there's like one
person who is like Miss save some email
and it's just like not aware they are
the problem and it's continuously
sending it out to the wrong thing I mean
I I find this whole situation so
ridiculous and at the same time like
hysterically funny I agree with you it's
like something out of the office is it
intense like is it like no no I want to
say God it's a little too vague but like
is there like a force that's mind
controlling these people to send it to
the Russian Ally like the I think it's
important dexterity I think they're just
they're rushing they could just be
stupidity but like Ian hold on are you
going don't attribute to stupidity what
you can attribute to Madness no I don't
think it's intentional I don't think
it's subconscious that should be a
t-shirt that's an Ian shirts
and they're like whether we realize it
or not we're contributing to the demise
of the liberal economic order I don't
know I don't think that's really
happening but it's interesting when huge
masses of people make the same mistake
from a long period of time it's also
interesting how much more invested
people aren't being careful when they
have a stake in something so for example
as someone who runs a business as
someone who's responsible for you know
gaining their own income through the
success of the operation that they've
created in our building like I'm pretty
careful when I send an email to a new
domain I want to make sure I got it
exactly right especially if I'm sending
information that I think could be you
know sensitive like a pitch guide or
like an nfla file or something that I
wouldn't want people outside of our
organization to have but these people I
think a lot of them they just don't feel
like they have that much of a stake so
they're not paying as close of attention
to what they're doing and you should
feel like you have a massive stake
because you're working for the Pentagon
think that's true with a lot of people
who have jobs these days yeah exactly
like they have a stake like have you
seen this thing where um what is it gen
Z there's that whole quiet quitting
thing there's the take it easy Monday
thing there's the uh I'm not gonna work
as hard as I really could thing there's
like a lot of this going on and it's
like um it's like a it's like
Civilization we have built civilization
up to be so big and powerful and huge
that it's going to take a while for it
to collapse but all of these things are
little pieces of collapse people not
taking a stake people not caring what
happens people thinking that they're
going to continue to get paid and have
jobs even if they stop doing any work
yeah it's one of the reasons I love
talking to people who own a small
business like uh locally there's Black
Dog Coffee in general injunction and I
was talking to a roaster who just like
started doing it for fun and then like
when he was working in construction and
he couldn't do that anymore in 2007 he
was like I'll just go full time and he's
bill built this business where like the
employees that I met there are like no I
just I really believe in what we're
doing and I like this product and I want
it to be good there is a sense of pride
of ownership and I love that yeah I love
that you have this idea that people are
like I am interested in this I'm
intellectually engaged in it but also
like I'm roasting coffee I I want it to
be a good product I want people to feel
satisfied like and maybe that I I feel
bad because I always uh sort of joke
with my friends who work for Corporate
America it's like oh you're just you're
corporate gals you have some jargon and
you do some meetings and like what what
are you even doing uh and of course
there are reasons to work for large
companies I don't want to be completely
uh against it but it is there is
something like I'm saying like when I
was talking to the Black Dog Coffee
Roasters I just really love hearing how
passionate about what they what they do
uh and I don't know I I wish more people
got to work in environments like that
because when you work for sort of bigger
Solace corporations when you feel
detached from your work it eats away at
who you are and you feel dissatisfied
thanks for watching this clip from the
Tim best IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time